ashley is in salem oregon
hey ashley welcome to the show how can
we help
hey dave well my husband and i are at a
standoff
my husband started a paint and remodel
business last year and in his first six
months produced 300k in production
this is our first full-year owning
business he's nearly at 600 for the year
wow and we haven't even started booking
for november or december
is he making a profit he is yes
we're doing very well and i'm actually a
stay-at-home mom
we have a one three and five-year-old
and due to the state of the world i'm
looking to home school next year and at
the moment
we're living in a two bed two bath 1100
square foot home with no yard
for all these kids um debt-wise we've
cleared all the 59 k in student loans
and our mortgage which is only 170
remaining our house is a little bit of a
unique situation
and this may be the best opportunity we
have to sell and make money with little
to no modifications on the home
the housing market out here is really
hot right now so i think we should sell
pay off the loans
get a house that suits our family and
the business which would put us on track
for baby step three to pay that mortgage
off
but my husband isn't budging on it he
wants to wait a year to see how the
business goes and says he won't move
until he's got 100k in savings to put
down which sounds crazy
um and my anniversary you know is
tomorrow i told him
the gift i would like is for him to
allow me to list the house and i will
assume all responsibility so he can
continue running the business
should we sell or should we sit here and
suffer for a year
and risk the market taking the crash
even though i know my husband isn't
going to let us fail so i think either
way we go we're going to be fine
[Music]
ashley how you guys don't have baby step
three correct
no they have 59 000 in debt oh you still
have 59 000 left in debt
no we're on baby step too so we're
paying off that debt but if we sold this
house
we would be able to pay off the mortgage
and our student loans
and then turn around and buy a house
that'll suit us for maybe 20 years
okay that part's not true but now you're
exaggerating
but yeah so ashley if i were you sorry
i'd love i would love to be on your team
on this call but i'm not going to be
i'm going to be with your husband
because i want you guys completely out
of debt
with a fully funded emergency fund
before you make another move
um but we have an emergency fund we've
got
um i don't even know how much but we
have a lot of money in savings
you don't know how much okay he has all
the numbers
i mean i feel like we've got at least 10
in savings that's not
we have a tax account for the business
that last year we had thousands and
thousands of dollars extra in that
because
he's really on top of that i think we've
got 10 000 in personal savings
that he just isn't touching and then we
have no credit card debt
no card debt nothing like that we just
have the 59 in the student loans and
then our mortgage which is 170.
the main issue here is that we live in
an 1100 square foot house with
three kids under five yeah totally and
then we have two bedrooms
i'm sleeping on the floor
um yeah why
um i i would sell the house
and rent but i would not i would not
i would not buy a house i would not buy
it i'm open to that as well a wrench is
fine i just want to get rid of this one
while the market is hot because i think
it's
smart well you're not wanting it to get
rid of it because the market's hot
you're running you want to get rid of
though because you're
you're exhausted and you have no room
with five people
in your family that's the more that
right because you wouldn't sell it's
really
that's why you want to sell not just
completely emotional but uh but i don't
mind if you want to rent
uh sell sell the house pay off the the
student loans
and build your three to six months and
if he wants a hundred grand in that's
fine you can sit there
and rent for two years sharon and i
actually did that we
we did it for a different reason we did
it to move school systems
and pull the kids out of private schools
rachel was in kindergarten denise was in
first grade
second and second grade thank you and um
you know we were paying private school
tuition because the schools in nashville
suck
and so we moved out of nashville into
the joining county where we've got great
schools and
uh rented for two years which is really
difficult for me because i have been in
real estate my whole life and
emotionally to sit there and rent was
ridiculously hard
sharon hated that rental house
to this day it was ugly though it was it
was really ugly but to this day
she gets an elvis lip sneer going
every time she mentions that oh that
house
every time we bring it up so it's not a
it's not a positive subject
and um but we got the kids into a
uh uh into a great school system
we cut that expense out and we made that
move
but we still were cleaning up so there
you go ashley i didn't even say i didn't
even think about renting
for you guys because you just own a home
so i immediately went to write to the
baby steps
but for you guys you can but you but you
can just go rent sell it and rent if
that's what you guys want to do for sure
because i'm with you as a mom i've got
three littles basically the same ages
and yeah i mean that's that's hard i get
it i totally get it
but you got to make decisions again not
based on emotion but based on facts and
you guys need to do what's best for your
family
financially and in the long run um while
keeping your sanity but
um you guys be on the same team too
ashley i feel like the way you were
wording everything was like well
he's this i'm that you guys need to find
that common ground and work together
because you're going to just get
so you're going to go so much faster
in this process working closely together
and being on the same team
yeah it's almost as if um
you know you're slamming your fist down
and saying i've got to do this and he's
trying to hold you back and be
responsible
and um you know and that
you both have to what rachel's saying is
you both have to identify what
responsible looks like
so responsible would be you clear your
debts and you have an emergency fund
before you buy a house
okay what rachel said at the beginning
of this now you can do that one of two
ways
you can sit there and endure the 1100
square foot with three littles for
one more year and it sounds like with
the numbers you've got you will be able
to do that in one more year
and you can do a lot of stuff for a year
there's a lot of people got it worse
than you
know i grew up in 100 square foot house
for 17 years
uh so somehow my mother my mother pulled
that off i don't know
which i don't i don't have scars that
i'm aware of from it
so um you know uh and we never moved
until i was 17 years old so um
you know lots of people have have
suffered
less and more rather
so you know you could do that for one
year it won't kill you but if you want
to move
and have a little better lifestyle a
little better situation and go rent for
a year
or two and do this in the right order
that's fine i would not
sell and immediately buy with no
emergency fund
absolutely would not do that if that's
your only
option between the two of you you need
to sit tight and
uh but if you're willing to move and
rent and
move again in two years after you get
everything straightened around you got
some reserves in the business you got
the down payment for the house or maybe
even
i mean you may even be able to pay cash
for a house almost the way you're going
because he's making bank
and he's doing a really good job
managing this not these numbers
and um and and
holding you off from running the thing
in the ditch
so um you know you give this guy credit
he's a stud
so well done kiddo you're gonna be all
right you'll get through it either way
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you guys jump in rachel talk about
that again
for the listeners this getting on the
same page thing
and you know like i remember your mom
and i had had a
argument not dissimilar to her she was
driving that old blue astro
van and she wanted a better car and i
had we had a block of money
and i needed to do some stuff that i
wanted to do some stuff at the office
that would take that block of money and
make it back five times over
and i'm trying to go do that and she
she's like i've had it with his whole
car
kind of similar conversation right to
what ashley's doing
and uh what we finally figured out was
that we were not head to head
that we got to do both it's just which
order we did it yeah which one first yep
which one's
first and getting on the same page is
everything it's that and les parrott
always says that he wishes he could give
a little box of empathy to everyone
and that's it you need to empathize and
put yourself
in your spouse's shoes you saying we're
he needs to do that for her because she
is at home with three boys that's what
i'm saying i would be
dying too i'll get it girl cracker box
with three littles i get that